hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy welcome to the homeroom live
stream we have a very exciting
show i guess you could call this a show
today where we're gonna announce the
2020 breakthrough junior challenge
winner but before we jump into that i
will give my standard announcements
reminder that we are not for profit we
can only exist through donations from
folks like yourself so if you're in a
position to do so please think about
going to khan academy.org
slash donate i also want to give a
special shout out to several
corporations that have helped us
over the years but especially during
kovid as we were already running at a
deficit our deficit only increased as
more and more folks have become
dependent on khan academy so special
thanks to bank of america google.org at
t fastly and novartis and it has helped
but we still have a gap especially for
2021 and many millions of dollars of
gaap so if you want to continue to have
tens of millions or
really hundreds of millions of folks
being able to
keep accessing their potential please
think about making a donation if you are
in a position to do so
last announcement there's a version of
this live stream that you can get as a
podcast wherever you typically get your
podcast if you go to homeroom with sal
the podcast
and with that i am excited to introduce
our first guest who is not the surprise
guest but then she will help me
introduce the surprise guest hilary and
alice hillary thanks for joining hillary
is the 2017
winner of the breakthrough junior
challenge welcome hilary
hi hi sal it's really amazing to be here
i'm really honored
no well i i still remember i'm you know
i'm one of the judges and i still
remember fondly your entry uh two two
three years ago uh well you know i am
curious before we introduce this year's
winner
what got what got what made you get you
know try to win the breakthrough junior
challenge
what was kind of your mindset into it
and how has it affected your life since
then
yeah so i actually joined it the first
time when i was in 11th grade in 2016 so
that's four years ago
and um i just for me it was a huge
gamble because i knew that the
breakthrough junior challenge was a
large competition right and so i was at
first really intimidated because if this
was international then i'm going to be
up against all these other really smart
high school kids from all over the world
but i just went through it anyway
because like i always say this i have
this mindset that if you fail you never
really fail you only learn and so i
carried that mindset with me so i tried
that the first time and i ended up
getting um the special prize that year
the popular vote and then
i tried again the next year um it was my
very last try because i was already 18
at that time so i was like okay i need
to i need to put everything
into this entry i need to invest a lot
of effort into it and so it really it
really just i guess it all worked out
and i and i did win that year and that
this competition has actually changed my
life so much i mean
for and even until now four years later
it's i feel like it's the gift that
keeps on giving it just
it has led me to mit it has led me to
science communication it has led me to
reach so many people all around the
philippines and the world and it's just
really changed my life so much
and i'm certain that it could make the
same kind of change for this year's
winner and i'm really excited to see how
it pans out for them as well
no i think what's really powerful about
is just the experience of doing it and
producing the videos and it doesn't just
take deep insight in math or science it
takes great communication skills great
creativity i think the winners are you
know i i tend to give extra points in my
head for the folks that can make me
laugh a little bit uh
and you were definitely one of so so
yeah
there's a lot of really cool skills that
come in come into this together well you
know i have more questions but i think
it would be fun to ask you
and the new winner so maybe we can
announce this together so
this year's
winner
for her video on quantum tunneling
miriam segaye
congratulations i had so many questions
for you i i guess both myself and
hillary have questions although i have
questions for both of you but i guess
first of all mariam um
what does it feel like to to win
absolutely crazy it's just unreal i'm
still absorbing it i don't know
it's just been
nothing's going to be the same from now
on and i'm just waiting and i'm on my
ride
yeah right
well before i dig deeper because i have
a ton of questions actually for both you
and hillary uh i think it's worth of
everyone taking a look at miriam's entry
and learn a little bit about quantum
tunneling
so i was watching my brother play this
video game and he used a cheat code that
let his character do a walk through
walls hack he pushed himself against a
barrier in the game hit some buttons and
boom his character appeared on the other
side imagine if he could walk through
walls in real life and it turns out you
can at a quantum level we're talking on
a scale of the stuff that makes up atoms
strange things happen at a quantum level
for one thing all subatomic particles
they've got split personalities one
personality is a wave and the other
one's a particle but there's still one
being when you want to know where they
are they seem like a particle and when
you want to know what they're doing they
behave like waves but you can't ask both
personalities at the same time basically
they've got some serious commitment
issues and that means we can only guess
where they might be imagine an electron
has two dice six sides each what the
electron rolls is where it will sit
along the line our electron can't commit
to a position until the dice are rolled
remember there's commitment issues so as
our electron is shaking the dice it's
everywhere at once something like us
trying to measure its position has to
force the electron to let go of the dice
and pick a spot of all combinations
getting a 7 is more likely than 2 or 12.
in reality though the electron can be in
more than just 10 spots since there are
many more combinations than just two
dice now we can picture subatomic
particles as this a probability wave
this wave will tell us the odds of
finding a particle at that location say
this is our electrons probability wave
the peaks of the wave is where we're
most likely to find the electron and in
the valleys it's less likely we find it
there let's say the electron is heading
towards a barrier as it hits the barrier
of the wing bounces off but let me tell
you something about waves they are not
perfect for example a beam of light
doesn't perfectly reflect off of the
surface a small fraction of light can
get through waves won't bounce off
perfectly so neither will the electron
wave sometimes the wave can slip through
the barrier when the wave is in the
barrier the chances of finding an
electron there goes down by a lot but if
the barrier is thin enough the wave can
reach the other side before it dies off
so what does that mean remember the wave
tells us how likely it is to find the
electron there this means there's a
chance we can find our electron on the
other side of the barrier or in there
too once it's on the other side we can
say the electron tunneled through the
barrier this is quantum tunneling and
that's how subatomic particles can walk
through walls okay so little elementary
particles can walk through walls but i
can't because my body's made up of more
than a quadrillion of these quantum
objects and the odds of all of them
tunneling through the wall is
practically impossible so why does
quantum tunneling even matter it's the
reason we're alive
quantum tunneling allows nuclear fusion
sounds familiar that's how our sun
releases huge amounts of energy that
makes life on our planet possible so how
can you quantum tunnel at home you
already are it's one of the ways our dna
mutates among other rules that quantum
physics plays in our biology quantum
physics makes it seem like the world is
playing cheat codes on us but it isn't
it's how the universe works maybe the
quantum world is telling us that when
faced with an obstacle there's a small
chance we can defy expectations and
reach barriers
[Music]
[Laughter]
i i i actually while re-watching it i
watched it obviously as a judge and
really enjoyed it but i i now see a
metaphor between quantum tunneling and
winning the breakthrough junior
challenge both of you all have quantum
tunneled
yes
to the other
uh well
mario let me ask you what why why did
you pick quantum tunneling and kind of
what were you thinking as you went
through the process
um
i didn't know what quantum tunneling was
and i at first i thought i was gonna
make my video on entropy but i was
watching a video about entropy and it
was talking about like the universe
reaches its
uh maximum entropy like quantum
tunneling will happen and the reason the
universe will like restart and it was
like wait wait what is quantum tunneling
what do you mean the universe will start
and and i i searched it up and i was
like how have i never heard about this
because there's a lot of like quantum
phenomena that you hear about but i've
never heard of quantum tunneling and it
i just kind of went down a rabbit full
of articles and stuff and i just thought
i can tell a story this is better than
entropy so i went with that
and i'm curious for both of y'all i mean
we start with mariam and then hillary
have y'all done videos before have y'all
done anything like this before this was
just kind of on a whim you said yeah let
me have a shot of that mario
uh yeah like at school we do have like
uh
like project based learning things so
like once you learn something you might
like make a video about it or something
uh we've definitely had video projects
before and i've made a few videos for
class
what about you hillary
well for me i definitely had zero
experience that's why at first i was
really hesitant to join the challenge
because it wasn't making videos but
i actually had experience in um
making graphic graphic design because i
used to make fan art for the show called
doctor who i was so obsessed
that i had i just had to make fan art
and that was when i learned the skill
like individuals
so
that's how we started
very very cool you know we have another
fun video this is this is an excerpt of
hillary's video from a couple of years
ago which is also a very you know there
i i thought i fully understood
relativity before i i watched it but
there's a couple of good uh metaphors or
visualizations you have there that that
were like oh yeah that's that's a really
cool way of thinking about it and
actually on the quantum tunneling side
as well uh but there's a fun video that
uh myself and scott kelly uh recorded uh
to surprise mariam and felipe if you
could show the video of mariam finding
out about her winning i believe that a
video creator's name was maryam one of
the things that i think we can do
together is two of the judges above many
others is maybe to speak directly to
mario
and you know i just want to let you know
mario you are the
winner junior challenge the 250 000
scholarship 100 000 science
they are yours
congratulations
so how tell us what was going on in your
head mariam when that was happening
i think my head just froze
there wasn't like there was no
processing or anything it was just like
disbelief and shock
like when i walked in to that room i was
told something completely different and
i just didn't think anything was going
to happen what what what did they tell
you what did they tell you was going to
happen like why why were you all there
it looks like y'all were in a socially
distanced classroom what was going on
yeah
so
we were told that we were coming to
school it was a friday where we didn't
have school and we were just told like
oh yeah you're gonna film like this
grade six uh video like to advertiser
school for sixth graders in town to come
and and then they're like oh actually
first uh alberta education wanted to
like film some stock
footage of kids like reacting to a
certain video and my principal mr barr
he's just like oh it's just i picked
this podcast for you guys to like
uh react to and i was like okay
i'm just like completely dismissing all
the clues that were happening like oh
it's all gone okay oh there's a filming
crew oh whatever oh it's it's not kelly
and falco oh nothing like you know
they're talking about the breakthrough
junior challenge it just never
i don't know
that's good so you have a healthy amount
of naivete about you which made the
surprise
which
which made that you're easy to surprise
which is always a good thing a good
thing in life well well you know hillary
you at the beginning you talked a little
bit about this but i'd love you to you
know kind of tell miriam what you know
what what what the world has in store
for her you know how have you used the
scholarship money the what happened with
the lab money what has your teacher done
have you know uh with the with the money
yeah so
i mean your life is never gonna be the
same after this and um right when i
think that i could um finally move on
for the research challenge i uh i keep
uh getting new cool things new
opportunities because of the stuff that
i did with the greatest junior challenge
so it's really amazing
and i mean of course it led me to
college here at mit it's fully free and
you it's really amazing to go to school
without having to think about money at
all and so i feel really grateful for
that and now that you have that
scholarship you will have that kind of
freedom also to pursue your own
interests without worrying so much about
money so that's always great and you
will also have so many opportunities to
meet cool people i mean just at the
awarding ceremony i don't know how
that's going to work this year because i
mean the panda like but you will meet so
many cool people and um in college
you'll you're going to meet even cooler
professors and then you might even i
don't know consider doing science
communication from now on because then
you're really good at explaining things
so that's like you have an app for that
and for me i kind of capitalized on that
uh after that after the greatest junior
challenge before the challenge i was
only thinking about doing pure
astrophysics but now i'm also
considering science communication and
like broader impacts as well so
that life is never going to be the same
from now on
i'm curious marian what are you thinking
about doing art you are a senior so you
are applying to college right now
yeah i am a senior i am not entirely
sure i know i want to
major in physics and
hopefully some kind of program that does
have like a more interdisciplinary
approach
to science and physics but i i know i
will
like in the future
or actually now from now on want to do
science communication i've always
admired science communication
yeah well i think both of y'all can do
both you know i always feel that if you
really understand something you should
be able to explain it or if you explain
it you should really be able to
understand it so i think they go hand in
hand if it's funny sometimes when i'm
doing research for something on khan
academy i'll call a friend who's an
expert in the field and i was like you
have this really what i think is
probably a dumb question why does a lead
to be there like that's actually a
fundamental question no one knows i was
like oh wow i've taught i've
touched on an area of i've touched on an
area of research and i have no doubt
that both of y'all uh are
are are going to do incredible things um
and i i actually i wonder i have so many
questions for both miriam and hillary i
remind everyone watching put questions
on youtube and facebook i'm going to
surface as many of those questions as
possible to uh mario and hillary mario i
got to say i don't think you're going to
have any trouble getting into college
i'm assuming your grades and test scores
are decent
[Laughter]
if you need a tutor let me know i don't
think you do um
and and i mean
yes
yeah yeah i mean you know not not to be
shameless about it but both of you all
do cite khan academy as playing some
role in your lives you know i don't want
to
don't want to shoot our horn too much
but
[Laughter]
but and i'll also say the part that that
event that hillary is referred to is
normally it's in november but because of
covet i think they're going to delay it
to march or whenever but they're still
going to do it and i have to say it is
the fanciest party that i go to every
year i bought a tuxedo just for that
party it's the only time in the year
that i wear a tuxedo and i go hungry
because the food is really good so i
look forward to hopefully seeing you all
there
so let's see there's there's a bunch of
um
questions here
uh let's see i mean there's one from
facebook which is just it feels like
just compliment which is always good to
receive peter
mastroianni says outstanding wonderful
communicator kudos makes an extremely
complicated and otherwise seemingly
impossible challenge challenging concept
understandable you will inspire and open
minds with your work applause so people
are loving and i think that's both of
y'all's work has has kind of met that
bar
um
you know smart bear five from youtube
hillary and mariam what are your future
plans you've touched on it a little bit
i mean maybe i'll start with you hillary
hillary are you a physics major or what
are you majoring in
yeah currently i'm a physics major here
at mit i also do research and um and
during the weekends i also do science
communication talks
in the philippines so i'm kind of been
doing both hand in hand
so where are you right now are you are
you distance learning from the
philippines or are you in in cambridge
i'm in mit actually i'm i'm on campus i
mean okay
oh very cool and what do you think what
do you think you're gonna do i know
still what are you you're a sophomore
junior
yeah i'm a sophomore right now and
right now the plan is to
um maybe pursue a phd so that's the plan
right now astrophysics i'm really
interested in that and
also do a lot of science communication
on the side i found that i really get
excited when i talk to people about
science and i feel like it's really
something i want to pursue in the long
term so i'm not sure what kind what form
science communication and you can be
very creative with how you pursue that
line of work
so i'll figure that out but for now i'm
just gonna keep on doing what i'm doing
that is talks and
doing problem sets in my physics
major very cool well you know going get
your phd you will make my mother proud
proud she still she still asked me
questions whether i could get like some
credit towards a md or a phd through my
khan academy work uh but and and and
mariam uh what about yours i mean i know
you're earlier you said you might be a
physics major are you thinking kind of a
similar attract to what hillary's
thinking of
yeah uh i know that i'd like to pursue
uh
research and like
physics and science and all that um and
more like interdisciplinary things i
don't know i don't like like the set
categories all the time for different
things um
and definitely science communication
because
yeah the world as a whole needs to work
on that
well i know an organization that could
use the benefit of people who know how
to make good science videos uh so i'll
i'll see if i can you know
connect you to some some people who have
influence there um so we should we
should talk about that
let's see other other questions you know
someone see facebook reda graham says
what is the most beautiful moment in
your breakthrough junior challenge i
guess you could interpret that question
however you see fit was it the moment
you found out about it was it the
creation was it telling your parents was
it
uh telling uh your teacher that they're
getting 50 000 i mean for i didn't talk
about the prices 250 000 scholarship 100
000 lab for your school 50 000 for uh
the the the teacher um what what you
know what and then obviously you get to
go to this great event and meet movie
stars and a couple of you know
non-profit directors who have their
tuxedo that they wear for that day um
who
what has been y'all's best moments uh so
far um i i don't know i'll start with
you mariam and then hillary you've had
more of the moments but mario you what's
what's been really standing out
um
i think the first moments were like the
creation of the video
um i was like i didn't know what i
wanted to do and the deadline was coming
close
so i was like okay i need to decide on
my topic and i knew like part of me
wanted to do quantum tunneling so like i
went out on a walk and i i babbled to
myself a lot and i was talking to myself
people would have been staring at me but
then i was like oh my goodness
like i think i can explain the
heisenberg uncertainty principle and
like all these things with like split
personalities and whatnot and and like
the video was like forming in my head
and um i was like imagining it as i was
walking and i was like oh my goodness
like taking out my phone every five
seconds and like writing something in
notes
i won't forget and i was like this is
going to work i can't wait to like
explain it like this and show people
that you don't need fancy equations to
understand the way particle duality and
schrodinger's wave function and all that
um and same with like it was mostly like
the explanations and stuff like coming
up with like the scripting that was like
that whole time it was like in this
state of flow and
um
yeah when i the whole dice analogy was
like another like i guess a light bulb
moment for me
um and yeah that was like i was really
excited to like get the video all
together
you know ever since seeing your video
i've been quoting you a few times every
time someone mentions electron i go you
know they have
commitment issues
[Laughter]
and hillary what about you what are what
are the moments that have really stuck
out for you
yeah for me i mean yeah as you said
earlier i've had more of those moments
than right now because it's been a while
but one thing that stuck out to me was
the my acceptance speech it was a really
nerve-wracking moment i wrote my
acceptance speech on the plane ride on
the way
to california so
i really like poured my heart out for
that really short acceptance speech and
i was really happy that i got to say
that in front of the world and it was a
live stream and all of that and it was a
really
amazing moment for me it's like winning
the oscars but in science and for high
school students so that was really for
me and another thing that stuck out to
me was when i talked to a bunch of
elementary school kids in the
philippines so i had gotten invited to
that event
it was a very impromptu event and one of
the organizers of that heard that i had
won the challenge and they invited me to
talk to all these kids they were really
tiny and they were fourth grade and
sixth grade and they were also energetic
and i talked to them about science and
about the hubble space telescope and all
these cool things and they were just so
energetic they had so many questions
and i feel like it was at that moment
when you really realized that talking to
people about science is really exciting
to me and i really find so much meaning
in it so i that's really what i decided
that i also wanted to do communication
apart from just pure physics
so
yeah
yeah absolutely and you know you
mentioned it's kind of like the oscars
and yuri milner who's really the driving
force behind the breakthrough junior
challenge that was his whole intent
which is we celebrate people in music
and and movies but really there are
people like changing the frontiers of
science and mathematics that
are doing things that are you know i
like movie stars too uh but but that are
doing things that are going to change
humanity and benefit humanity they need
to be awarded the same way and also
young people who can communicate science
uh which will you know when you
communicate science that's how i always
think about my job at khan academy you
know i i do still secretly hope that i
might be able to like create some new
math theorem or or you know find some
new particle or something but i also
like to think that by the way by
communicating the science that there's
going to be folks like y'all millions of
them and one of y'all are going to
figure out how to you know travel at
warp speed or you know solve climate
change or cure cancer um and so i think
that's the real power of science
communication which both of y'all are
already on a on a fast track you know
maybe one final question for both of you
what advice would you have for
a young person like yourself a year or
two or three years ago who's like well
yeah i i think i could do it but gee
it's so hard you know a lot of your
doubts that y'all had uh maybe start
with you hillary what advice would you
have for for someone who is thinking
about it or maybe is a little bit afraid
to to throw their hand in the ring yeah
so my first advice would be to to just
not be afraid i always say this and i
said this earlier when you fail you
don't really fail you only learn
i have said that a number of times and
i'm always surprised at how much it
resonates with people because i mean we
all feel that that way sometimes right
we feel like we've kind of failed but if
you look at it from a different
perspective take it as a learning
experience a learning opportunity then
it won't feel too bad at all and then it
will make you even braver to pursue
better opportunities to enrich yourself
to meet new people and all these things
so
definitely
don't uh take anything as a failure take
it as a learning experience
that's my advice
and what about you mario
i think i mean i found out about the
challenge
five years ago and i didn't think i
could get anywhere with it
um because i'm always like intimidated
by the other videos and the other like
older teams and everything
um but
if you're if someone watching is
thinking about participating in the
breakthrough junior challenge i just
want to let you know you don't it
doesn't take a lot i was working on like
a half broken computer and my friend was
helping me edit on his like shattered
ipad and we were
like we don't have like any professional
video making abilities or like software
and like
all the animations in my video were made
with google slides it doesn't take a lot
so you should at least try
and
and um because the focus is obviously on
the communication not necessarily your
editing abilities and if you if you love
science and
want to share science then just go for
it
no well that resonates a lot with me
because both of your videos are like
high-tech pixar compared to mine so you
get
i'm definitely on the lower production
end of of things but you know this this
is a real treat i i look forward to
seeing you both i hope everyone watching
you know there was an amazing finalist i
mean both of y'all had a lot of other
strong competitors you know i think
y'all were a notch above
everyone else but congratulations to
everyone who is a finalist and you know
i've got to believe that even the folks
who didn't quite get to where you all
are but got to the finalists that
hopefully the the process of making the
videos means a lot you know i always
whenever someone applies for a job i'm
like what have they made so you know
hopefully everyone uses their videos as
their calling cards to show how they
both can understand difficult concepts
but also communicate it and i just want
to thank you both because
even though uh hopefully what the
breakthrough junior challenge is
providing you is going to be a great
foundation for the rest of your life and
it feels like y'all might be the ones
winning the prize i genuinely feel that
it's society that's going to win the
prize because it's going to unlock your
abilities to do more for all of us so
thank you so much and keep communicating
and and keep pushing the frontiers of
science both both mario and hillary
thank you
thank you so much
well thanks everyone for joining you
know i really encourage you to look at
we saw mariam's video rewatch it it is
actually probably the best exam
explanation of quantum tunneling you can
find i also encourage you to watch
hillary's video probably the best
explanation of relativity you can find
and also look at the other breakthrough
junior challenge winners over the last
several years and actually the finalists
a lot of really great concepts i'm
watching them with my kids uh that it's
probably the best way to expose yourself
to some concepts in math and science
that most folks think are beyond them
but really really aren't so take a look
at it and uh thanks for joining today
and i look forward uh to seeing i'm
fighting the sun the sun shows up at
around this time of day in my in my in
my closet um uh but i look forward to
seeing y'all at the next homeroom with
sal thanks for joining us today
and yes we will have the head of teach
for america alisa villanueva beard to
discuss on wednesday so see y'all then
you